so wherever your desire is that's where
your mind will be if you desire
something intensely your mind will be
always there right now you desire the
cup wrong place to be you desire a goal
that's what you should desire when
you're on the field isn't it now you can
decide the cup but once you're on the
field you just desire the goal and go
and go nothing else once your desire is
strong your body and mind naturally
lives in the direction isn't it whatever
you desire that's where you go if your
desire falls off then you can't keep the
mind on it you just have to develop the
icha in you the only itcher is to score
the cop then you don't have to worry
about mental focus that's where the mind
will be can somebody take your mind off
what you desire can somebody take your
mind off what you desire what you desire
is where your mind will naturally go
isn't it need motivation watch a top ten
belief Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because in my
first business I quit on my business
partner I was making 300 bucks a month
and I didn't have the motivation to keep
going and the thing that got me through
was studying the stories of
entrepreneurs who've had massive success
and I hope that in sharing these stories
with you you find a motivation to keep
going and if I'm being honest I still
need the stories for myself today too so
today let's learn from one of
sad Guru and my take on his top 10 rules
of success enjoy
so how does yoga help in this
see what are the simple parameters with
which the body and mind is functioning
this is a complex machine
this is the
marketing machine
in this planet is human body and mind
isn't it
everything that we have created has come
out of this mind so this mind is a
complex missionary very complex
no no no no
no no no no no
so if you do anything wrong it will
create many distractions within itself
there are some simple ways there is some
simple technology with which you can
keep your mind in a certain condition of
clarity where it's in disease that you
learn to keep your mind like a mirror it
simply shows you what is there it
doesn't distort
the moment your mind gets identified
with many things now you are playing as
an Indian hockey player now you get all
this started because now you're reading
the whole history the glory of Indian
hockey the depths of Indian hockey
everything will flow in your mind now
you will not play the game you will not
see the game the way it is first of all
learning to keep the mind like a mirror
where it simply shows you what is there
in front of you without any distortion
once there is no Distortion you will
walk to the best of your ability isn't
it
now you're walking on this floor there
is no Distortion in Your Vision you can
see everything clearly to the best of
your ability you will go isn't it in
your very Vision if there is distortion
you will unnecessarily stumble all over
the place
so whatever talent you have whatever
capability you have if it has to find
full expression your mind doesn't come
in between and distort anything it just
shows you everything the way it is
so the whole yogic system is focused on
this for a spiritual purpose which can
also be used for the sport that it shows
you everything just the way it is not
some other way not the way you think it
is number two stay motivated this is
another concept which is made it around
in the world that something else should
motivate you to do what you're doing
foreign
[Music]
enough you don't need any other thing to
motivate you
what you're doing is truly significant
to life why do you need another
motivation to make that happen
if if you really understand and
experience that what you are doing is
truly important for every life around
you
you don't need a motivation life just
goes on see
does your heartbeat need a motivation to
keep it going
I'm asking you
all the life processes is not asking for
any motivation isn't it monsoon's coming
any motivation no it's coming year after
year because the natural process is
going on simply like that and you and me
life is on
what I'm telling you is if you're doing
something which is aligned with the
fundamental life process of Who You Are
this can find a million Expressions it
need not be just spiritual teaching it
can find a million Expressions that what
you're doing is aligned with your
fundamental life process then you will
not need anything to motivate you
simply as a part of life it will just
happen
how much you do simply depends on how
much time you invested on upgrading
yourself
the problem with the world right now is
people are always trying to upgrade
their activity
if you upgrade your activity without
upgrading yourself
you are bound to break up somewhere it's
like
you went on a Formula One Track because
you want to be on a fast track
and you went with your maruti 800
suppose you hit the right kind of speed
all the four wheels will go in four
different directions
it won't hold up
if you want to be in that kind of speed
and that kind of track you must repair
the machine upgradation of this one is
important if you upgrade yourself
activity will simply happen
uh many people around me
you know many times think I am
superhuman because of the activity that
I perform
this is not about being superhuman if
you explore the possibilities of Being
Human if you explore the possibilities
of the immensity of Being Human you will
realize
you don't have to be a superhuman Being
Human itself is super
so you will not need any external drive
or some other inspiration the very
process of life will do it rule number
three build your trust if you're stupid
you can do whatever you want
you need to understand trust does not
mean
somebody has to behave the way you
expect them to behave
trust means whatever they do it's all
right with you
if you come to such a state otherwise
don't use such a big word as Trust
trust means they must do what you expect
them to do
this is a certain imprisonment you trust
trust should Empower people trust should
not limit people isn't it
so your idea of trust is to hold them
in the way you want them to be
so you trust betrayal this that works
don't get into all this nonsense
just use your sense see this is the
biggest mistake they have made they
always told you
to be good
once you are good you have all these
expectations from everybody else see
first of all they told you God is good
God is compassion God is love God is so
many things
live what other people have told you
let's say you know nothing of this
nonsense from anybody you paid attention
to Creation you looked at a flower
carefully
one thing you can see is whatever
created this is of tremendous
intelligence isn't it
yes or no
not necessarily something as pleasant as
a flower you pay an attention to an ant
that's crawling around the way it's made
incredible intelligence or no
yes or no but nobody told you God is
intelligence
if they had told you God is intelligence
we would have had a more sensible world
so
don't don't get into all this trust
business
handle your life and relationship
sensibly
because these things will create
expectations which no human being can
fulfill
and simply struggles will happen endless
struggles will happen
trust means I trust somebody means
whatever they're doing I trust them
no I trust them means they must do only
what I expect them to do this is not
trust this is a soft imprisonment
you know
in it's still not come to India maybe
but everywhere else they got they got
callers for the dog electronic callers
no more chains the dog will be right
there it'll never leave the boundary
because if it crosses that boundary
there will be a shock
okay and in America it's become very
common it runs around only in your
garden it won't run anywhere no offense
no chain but the dog cannot run out
because if it steps out
why why are you making faces it's called
lakshman Rekha in India
if you cross that there will be trouble
so that's what she's talking about in
the name of trust if you cross it there
will be trouble
don't don't get into this dog tag kind
of trust
if you really trust somebody whatever
they do they may be doing it in their
own understanding of life
everybody is working according to his
intelligence and his understanding isn't
it
yes
right now probably that's all they're
capable of
if you can evolve them to another place
fantastic if you cannot then you must
see what to do
but do not bring in such words of trust
trust should not become a way of
capturing people trust should be a way
of liberating people rule number four
wake up before the sun the greatest
predicament
that a human being faces
and the greatest tragedy that human
beings are going through
and the greatest struggle
that all humans seem to be toiling with
is just this
their sensory perception gives one-sided
perception
if you see this you can't see this if
you see light you can't see Darkness if
you hear sound you can't hear silence
so life becomes
a heap of opposites or contradictions
trying to wear their way through these
contradictions how much suffering
unbelievable
how much confusion how much struggle
if this nearly 8 billion people if you
document what kind of suffering they are
going through in one year or in one day
just one day
it's enough for eternity
all this is simply because
they have misunderstood
instruments of survival
or as instruments of knowing
you must know which is light and which
is Darkness if you want to walk through
this
you must know which is man which is
woman if you have to operate in the
world
so these differences
are very one-sided
well in many ways I've said this now
it's become a bit uh
too common for everybody to know this
because I've been speaking about this
for some time while you are sitting here
with a man or a woman but you came here
because a man and woman came together
your mother and father exists within you
you being a woman or a man is just a
surface thing but you've taken it so
seriously and you go through a whole lot
of circus just being a man or a woman
how much circus in the world
forget about light and darkness that's
more complicated
it's the simplest damn thing but how
much struggle how how much Social
confusion how many how many religions
and scriptures have been written about
this misunderstanding endlessly
it's just that
because
between light and darkness
you think they are two different worlds
because it looks like that the day looks
like one kind of world this planet looks
different during the day during the
night it's a completely different world
but it is not it's the same world
I think you get that point during
Twilight to some extent this is why it's
always important to wake up before the
sun comes up
because you don't have to do anything if
you're just alert and looking
slowly the perception will go into you
this is why I always in yoga Brahma
mortam you should be up because Twilight
starts then
in Twilight if you're awake you perceive
that the differences that you have made
out in your mind because
of misperceptions of senses that you
have settles within you
when that happens when
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five take proper
action Karma means action there are four
types of action physical mental
emotional and energy
of all these things the energy action is
the most important one and the most
enduring one and the most liberating one
if you do it the right way
if you do it the wrong way
the energy action which is improper
can have far more impact upon one's life
than the improper physical actions
improper mental actions improper
emotional actions
so what do I mean by improper energy
actions
one thing is
unfortunately I had to witness a few
things which I did not wish to witness
certain people trying to misuse
a little flexibility in energy
that came with
certain practice of yoga
or a certain initiation especially there
are some over smart people that when you
initiate them when it's fresh when
they're bursting with energy they want
to use it for something else
they want to channelize it to impress
their neighbors or to make some money
out of it or in some way use it
what was offered to them for their
well-being they try to do something else
that can happen or
example would be
see there are there are many ways you
can perform negative action one thing is
let's say you sat here and thought that
somebody that you don't like Must Die
or you even taught how to kill them
it has a certain level of impact on you
on another level you had a thought
but not just a thought the strong
emotion now it has a much deeper impact
upon you
you acted upon this thought and emotion
and you actually performed the action
then it has a much deeper impact on you
now
you understand that if you perform these
actions there may be consequences so you
found another way
you found somebody who will do certain
type of energy action through which
the person that you don't like will die
there is an entire science like this
one Veda among the four Vedas is
dedicated to this this is called
where it's about learning to use
energies towards your benefit and other
people's detriment
you've heard of words like black magic
wudu and
Billy sunyam and whatever else you call
it
where people have learned to use
energies to cause harm to someone else
once you energetically try to influence
somebody
for some benefit of your own
now this will be the worst Karma because
the impact of this goes very deep into
you because you're employing your
energies to do this
this is the reason why
even to initiate you into a simple
process like sambhavi
I am asking you to take the step of
being a mother to the world so that you
never misuse this you see everybody as
yours
because enhancement of Energies
to come with a profound sense of
responsibility
enhancement of energies has to happen
with deeper dimension of inclusiveness
without inclusiveness if you use energy
this will be the worst karma karma
so
those of you who find
some dramatic changes happening in your
life
because of initiations
you must take care you must take at most
care that you never try to use
this ability to transform to do
something else
of course some of you think you will do
a great thing by healing Somebody by
intervening in somebody's life in some
other way
no you this will be the worst type of
karma you perform because once you try
to use your Energies
and still you are capable of anger
you are capable of drawing boundaries of
what is you and what is not you what is
yours and what is not yours when these
things are still there you should never
ever try to do anything energetically
because this will be the most impactful
Karma that you will do
this is the reason why even the basic
practice of shambhavi to initiate you
you must become a mother to the world
and this is also a fantastic way to beat
your karma if every moment of your life
if you live with an inclusive emotion of
being a mother to the world
not discriminating between what what is
yours and what is not yours right now
you cannot help discriminating what is
you and what is not you but at least
what is yours and what is not yours if
you take it away
you have solved the karmic puzzle 90
percent believe me 90 percent
of all dimensions of karma you have
solved that puzzle remaining 10 percent
I am that rule number six don't demand
respect respect is not something that
you ever demand in your life
please don't ever do such a vulgarity
that you demand respect
you can only earn it you cannot demand
it the moment you demand it it becomes
well God you should know
so you stand One Step higher than
somebody and you demand respect or the
only stupid thing that you did is you
came here a few years earlier than
someone else and your demand that I'm
senior it must be happening in the
college also one year senior time you
better respect me yeah
just one year ahead I joined the college
and now I am Senior okay
so this is an unfortunate reality that's
well established in the world
that
in the name of religion
in the name of authority in the name of
Parenthood
in many different ways
we have been trying to establish
Authority is the truth
No Authority is not the truth truth is
the only Authority
this is why Youth and Truth
truth is the only Authority
nothing else is the authority
so if I ask a question somebody freaks
see
if you ask a question somebody freaks
because they don't know the answer
suppose you go sit in an examination and
look at the question paper you don't
know a damn thing don't you freak just
like that they're freaking why don't you
understand
[Music]
so you
question paper you have no clue do you
freak or no
so they are also freaking
so you must understand and be little
compassionate when you ask a question
somebody freaks means obviously they
don't have an answer so you must be
compassionate considerate because
they're your seniors
they came ahead of here ahead of you but
they are no better than you so they're
freaking a bit
please make way for them what to do they
grow a little bigger than you
but at the same time there is no need
for anybody to succumb to that
it's all right there is no need to
confront people a question first of all
say a question is a tool
a question is a tool to dig a Little
Deeper isn't it
hello
but somebody's asking a question to
prove a point that's not good
so don't ask a question to your parents
or to somebody else just to prove your
point now ask a question because it's a
genuine question
so people were asking me what kind of
questions can we ask what can we not ask
I said even the dumbest question you
have if it means something to you it
means something to me
if it doesn't mean anything to you don't
ask such stupid things because it
doesn't mean a damn thing to me either
but if it means something to you maybe
it's a stupid question somebody thinks
it's a stupid question but it means
something to your life
it means a lot to me
so please make sure your questions are
genuine whether you ask a parent or a
political leader or a spiritual leader
it doesn't matter who the hell you ask a
question when you ask a question you
must understand the purpose of asking a
question is to expand yourself from what
you know to enter a territory where you
do not know something that's the idea of
asking a question
but you ask a question to prove them
stupid
then maybe they're getting mad
you're entering their territory now
but you have to make sure in your life
because your life is not just about your
life how you conduct your life will
determine the nature of this world isn't
it so
when you have such a responsibility you
have to ensure that truth is the only
Authority
Authority is not the truth
it doesn't matter whether it's parents
or teachers or spiritual teachers
political leaders or God himself came
down and he said something stupid
you must be able to question him that is
the nature of this culture see even when
those entities which we considered
Divine came
in India all we did is ask questions
endless questions when Shiva came
his wife Parvati freaks him with a
million questions
when Krishna came Arjuna asked thousand
questions questions and questions and
questions I must tell you this we were
trekking in Tibet
a group of people
almost from 42 different countries
so an Indian man who settled in United
States
was uh wanted to ask a question I said
you can ask questions immediately raised
his hand and he stood up he asked a
question which lasted over eight minutes
and it was going on I said see this is
too long a question
then I told others because they were all
looking like this because they are from
different nations they can't understand
this question I said see this is a very
Indian question
another
question inside a question inside a
question
Indians are experts in this because they
have 15 000 years of culture they've
crafted questions like this
why it doesn't matter Shiva comes
Krishna comes they want to bowl a googly
to him
that's the whole intent
so I said this is an Indian question and
I try to explain to them
what is an Indian mind and why it asks
such questions
so much of culture then one Chinese lady
she said Guru I was working at the
United Nations even there only Indians
ask questions
we never ask questions only the Indians
were asking questions all the time I
said that is India rule number seven be
a creator
you don't have to be on the go all the
time
if life demands people ask me how are
you active like this because generally
my schedule is anywhere between 18 to 20
hours a day seven days of the week 365
days non-stop for many years it's going
on
I'm complaining and the guy's clapping
about it
[Laughter]
so people keep asking how do you keep
yourself like this how do you do this
see I'm essentially lazy
it's just that
the situation in the world demands
action
left to myself I would close my eyes and
simply say it
I am made like this if I close my eyes I
can sit like this till I fall dead
really I have really no need for Action
I'm not trying to keep myself busy
there's a lot to be done so you're doing
people ask me sadhguru what's your dream
what is your dream I said my dream is
the day I am unemployed that's a great
day because if I am unemployed it simply
means everybody is doing fantastic
what more do you want dream fulfilled so
action is not something that you decide
you just decide your intent
action the world will decide how much of
what
I am you know at these economic forums
and stuff I'm a world economic forum
this guy in front of Business Schools in
Harvard Business School one Professor
comes oh you're that amazing tree
planter
I said no I'm not a tree planter he said
no no you planted those Millions yes I
did but I'm not a tree planter
then what do you do I said uh I make
people flowers
not plant trees but I'm planting trees
because the goddamn trees are missing
where they should have been
where they should have been they are not
there it's like this two men were
working on the street
one man is digging pits behind him
another man is coming and closing and
closing and going
somebody else was driving by they saw
this ridiculous Activity one guy digs
the pit another guy closes the pit so
they stopped and said hey what are you
doing here why are you guys working like
this one guy digging another guy closing
they said no no
the in between guy has gone and leave
he's the tree planter
he's not there we're doing our work so a
lot of people are doing work legs I'm
doing my work
you have no work on this planet the
planet needs work if the world needs
work we will do it otherwise why should
I think this is my work
so Guru what's your mission so no
Mission I'm just fooling around a bit
because
you have no business
to have your own mission
life has its own mission in some way if
you can assist and serve that that's
about it what is it that you have your
own mission are you some kind of a
tyrant all missionaries are tyrants in
some way unknowingly yes those who think
they have a mission there is no Mission
what is needed you do especially when
you study in a business school and get
certain competence to manage things or
create things
you must create what is needed not
create some rubbish and push it on them
yes
yes or no
you must see how to make life better how
to solve situations which are
problematic to a whole lot of people you
must look for Solutions and solutions
for the existing situations and of
course there are experts who go on
creating new problems
so you will never be short of problems
believe me
you just have to create Solutions not go
on a mission mode rule number eight
overcome loneliness you must decide
what is the highest value in your life
freedom
or bondage
please I would like to hear that word
but
if you are free you feel lost
if some if you go into the mountains
and you're totally free that is nobody
around nothing around your chest in the
empty space of the mountains
you don't feel free you think you're
lost
so to handle Freedom it needs a certain
Clarity and strength
most people cannot handle freedom
they are always trying to bind my bind
themselves but only talking mouthing
Freedom all the time if you really set
them free they will suffer immensely
so this is uh
evolutionary issue
in the sense
human beings are right now like this a
caged bird if you keep a bird cage for a
long period of time and then one day you
took off the door of the cage
still the bird won't fly
from inside it will protest that it's
not free but it will not fly
Human Condition is just that
for all other creatures nature is drawn
Two Lines within which they have to live
and die and that's what they do
but only for human beings
there's only bottom line there's no Top
Line
and that's what they're suffering
if their life was also fixed like every
other creature's life they wouldn't be
stressed they wouldn't be anxious they
wouldn't be struggling how to handle
their own intelligence
and that is what you're seeking
unknowingly
you may have seek it in the form of
relationships you may seek it in the
form of profession you may seek it in
the form of form of nationality
ethnicity community
God heaven have all you are trying to do
is draw an artificial line which does
not exist
because Freedom needs courage
Freedom needs I said Madness
laughs
if you're very sin you cannot be free
because you will go between the two
lines of logic
to be free it takes a lot of strength
that if you first of all what needs to
happen if you want to be free is
[Applause]
do you understand that all Human
Experience
has a chemical basis to it
hello
what you call as Joy is one kind of
chemistry misery is another kind of
chemistry stress is one kind of
chemistry
anxiety another kind of chemistry Agony
one kind of chemistry ecstasy another
kind of chemistry at least ecstasy you
know it's another kind of chemistry
I hear
so your experience of life has a
chemical basis to it there's a more
superficial way of looking at it there
are the dimensions to it but for your
understanding
or in other words what you call as
myself right now you're a chemical soup
the question is only are you a great
soup or a lousy soup
yes or no
right now if you have a chemistry of
blissfulness
if you close your eyes it's fantastic if
you open your eyes it's fantastic if
somebody is here it's fantastic nobody's
here it's very fantastic yes or no
but you have a lousy chemistry
if you look at them if they smile at you
it's nice not fantastic if they look at
you like this suddenly it's a problem
if these people are happening just the
way you want your chemistry is
reasonably balanced
if they do something that you don't like
boom it goes somewhere else
so essentially
you have not looked at this mechanism
what is the basis of this how it
functions how I can make it function at
its highest level
right now let's say you really blissed
out like me
do you care who is around who is not
around
if they're around it's fantastic they're
gone fantastic
because your experience of life is no
more determined by what you have and
what you don't have whether it's people
or things or food or this or that it is
not determined by that
once your way of being is not determined
by anything outside of you
then
there is no such thing as loneliness
but you will enjoy your aloneness
because whether you like it or you don't
like it at this young age it's a little
uh difficult to understand this whether
you like it or you don't like it within
this body you're always alone isn't it
whether you do interaction or
intercourse or whatever whatever
still you're alone in this body yes or
no
hello
[Applause]
if you don't learn how to handle this
aloneness you have not learned anything
about life
this is the most beautiful thing
the most beautiful thing about life is
nobody can get here it's just my space
yes or no
isn't this the most beautiful thing
nobody can invade me they can capture me
they can torture me they can do so many
things but they cannot invade me because
I have a space which is just my own
isn't this the most wonderful aspect of
your life
don't suffer that that is the most
beautiful thing rule number nine live a
life of joy we are thinking of Happiness
like it's some kind of a commodity
or some kind of an attainment
no when your life comes to ease when you
come to ease
happiness is a natural consequence
coming to ease what does it mean there
are many ways to look at this
well
because uh I should not say look inward
to already put a condition on me
so is it true that today even medically
we know
every human experience has a chemical
basis to it
so what you call as peace is one kind of
chemistry happiness is another kind of
chemistry Joy is another kind of
chemistry misery is another kind of
chemistry Agony is one kind of chemistry
ecstasy is another kind of chemistry
every human experience has a chemical
basis to it
or in other words
you are a very complex chemical soup
the question is only are you a great
soup or a lousy soup
if you're a great soup you taste good
not for somebody for yourself when you
taste very good for yourself if you sit
here if you feel extremely Pleasant
within yourself because the soup is
great
then people say you are happy
if you become very very pleasant people
say you're joyful if you become super
Pleasant people will say you're ecstatic
so
to make it very simple and
understandable for most people
your Chemistry needs to be altered
there's a whole technology with which we
can create the kind of chemistry that
you want if I teach you how to create a
blissful chemistry within yourself
your very chemistry is blissful and you
will be Blissful when you're Blissful
you will no more be in Pursuit of
Happiness that is the biggest mistake
that we are in pursuit of happiness
your life has to become an expression of
joy
when your life is an expression of your
experience
then
what you do what you do not do will not
determine the quality of your life how
you are within yourself will determine
the quality of your life I am sorry once
again I use the word within but
chemistry is not within it is still
outside of you
but
if you know how to make the right soup
then being joyful is not an issue it's a
natural consequence of that
so we can teach you a technology we can
teach you a methodology with which
you will know how to stir the right kind
of soup within you
this is what I am calling as in
engineering that you engineer your
Chemistry in such a way that it's
Blissful by its own nature not because
of something if you think you're going
to squeeze happiness out of something or
somebody
you will be disappointed because nothing
will yield anything
unless you have a chemistry of
blissfulness within you and Rule Number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is liberate yourself Karma
[Music]
probably
one of the most
misunderstood words
for sure it's become part of the English
lexicon today
but misunderstood
and misinterpreted in a million
different ways
a range of things
the very way
the nature of karma is just like that
its interpretations
the karmic structure is a very complex
mess
but
there is a
there are
very uh what to say very descriptive
stories
in the Indian culture about
the type of jewelry the courtesans used
to wear
that is very famous courtesans were
covered in gold and diamonds
no clothes only jewelry covered their
body
such complex jewelry
that
when
when the man who came to them
they had no clue how to take off this
jewelry because it was such a complex
web of change
try as hard as they did but they cannot
get this Jewelry off
jewelry is beautiful
but
for a man who is
whose mind is running right with lust
this is a barrier
so usually uh
she encourages him to drink and drink
little more and little more
so that he sleeps
and gifts are more jewelry and goes home
but when she wants to take it off
there is just one pin normally located
at where ourana is this one pin if she
proof pulls the entire jewelry falls
down in one's
just like that it falls down
Emma is like this it's a complex web of
chains
some of them of course decorated with
diamonds
some are ugly some are rusted chains but
change and change and change but there
is just one single pin
[Music]
only because
you are not able to consciously find the
PIN
the fundamental reason
let me tell you the fundamental reason
why there is a culture or there is a
tradition of
depending upon a guru
for one spiritual growth is just this
that you want him to
pull the plug when the time is right
because in this complex web of change
you don't know where the pin is
right now if you try to find it
you can go on a search Forever and not
find it and if you find it just in case
if you find it
you will dismantle it in such a way that
you will dismantle your very life
to dismantle it skillfully that just
what just the karmic aspect falls off
and you exist as a liberated being that
takes lots of skill it is for that skill
that you come to your Guru
it is your karma that you have to endure
me
if you had figured it out yourself you
didn't have to bother about me
so sadhguru when are you going to pull
my plug
that means it's not you're not ready yet
if you have if you
are in a state where you think your
karma is a burden and you must get rid
of it
you are not yet ready for it
if you come to a state where
you have learned how to transform every
memory conscious and unconscious
Pleasant and unpleasant
beautiful and horrendous ones everything
into well-being
if you come to that state then it will
be good for me to pull the pins
now if you pull the pin because
this is not Liberation this is an escape
there is difference between walking out
of this body
and committing suicide they're two
different things all together
committing suicide means you want to
escape a difficult situation
walking out of this means
your term is over your time is up so
they've released you
these are two different things
completely
if you escaped from the prison you will
have to run for the rest of your life
but if you're freed from the prison
because your term is up then you're a
free man that's a big difference
if you are very clear that what you're
doing is significant
for every life around you
other people's opinion means nothing
but but I'm saying for 30 years plus
they've been saying the same things
they're not even creative they're not
able to come up with anything new
all right same things they are saying
but they've not gotten anywhere because
they have no substance
there's no substance with anything that
they have said
so
it's unfortunate
that they're in that state
but what I see is every daily Mystic
court is there you know daily quote
all these people are just waiting
one thing that they don't understand
suddenly all of them will get together
and make it make their Twitter trend
I'm so glad
because every day they're reading my
course even people who are here are not
reading
they're reading okay I am saying every
day carefully they're reading my code
the day they don't understand they think
I've made a mistake
and boom they'll go
I'm glad I worked in prisons both in
India and United States I worked with
hardcore criminals welcome for murder
rape worst possible things that a man
can do for those things they have come
and I've seen significant transformation
with uh in their lives simply because of
two days or five days of contact with me
these guys are continuously following me
I am very confident one day they will be
very transformed I wish them the best
human attention
has
shifted to many things that we could do
that we are not able to do right now
but one large area
which has been left unexplored
is the human being itself
whatever kind of Technologies we develop
whatever kind of machines we build
essentially we can only
think of doing something which is an
extension of our existing faculties
see if you were made like a tree that is
rooted to one place
would you have
thought of a bicycle
hello
only because you already have Mobility
you thought about enhanced Mobility
that evolved into many things
only because we can speak
we came up with a microphone and a
telephone
if we had no such thing as speech
would we have thought of a microphone on
a telephone
because we can see
we have microscopes and telescopes
every machine and every Gadget we create
is only enhancement of existing human
faculty
we can say this far but we want to see
that form
we can speak this for now we want to
speak that far
we can hear this for now we want to hear
from somewhere else
everything
there is no other way for a human brain
or human intelligence to function
we will only
think of how to enhance this
the purpose of enhancement
is essentially
a longing to enhance the quality
the content and the profoundness of our
life you don't have to eliminate the
waste waste is very valuable if you know
right now in this Garden they buy wasted
a very and you know a very exorbitant
price because their waste goes into the
public system they have to buy waste
from somewhere they have to buy filth to
fertilize yes yeah so whether you turn
your filth into a fertilizer or you
smear it on your face and walk around
that's your choice this is why Karma
so what kind of karma happened in my
life till this moment is not always my
choice so many things have happened but
what kind of karma I perform right now
in this moment is 100 my choice will I
use this filth as manual and Blossom
into your wonderful fragrance or will I
smear it around me and walk around with
filth this is the choice everybody has
when unpleasant things happen to us
which happens to everybody in some way
if you're living in the world I'm saying
unless you drop from somewhere else
right if you're living in this world so
many unpleasant things happen
now with these unpleasant things do you
become wise or do you become wounded
this is a choice to exercise this Choice
there must be a little space when I say
a little space where is your memory
stored
people think here your brain has very
little memory okay
every cell in the body carries a
trillion times more memory than your
entire brain
every cell in the body every cell in the
body because if I take one cell from you
we can you know create you completely in
a lab that means what well your parents
your father and mother gave you only one
sell each they were not very generous
only one cell each see a whole man came
out of it yeah
so in that one cell all this memory head
to toe everything was there isn't it
yeah no mistake texture of the hair
texture of the skin the nails the works
every detail to the minutest detail was
it packed in that one cell or no yeah
yes so every cell in your body carries a
trillion times more memory than your
entire brain carries wow so if you do
not use that if you just use one part of
your body then everything seems to be
stressful everything seems to be a
struggle today everybody complaining
about everything everything is stressful
you are a toddler you have stress of
diapers you are a teenager you have
hormonal stress your middle age you have
crisis your old age geriatric stress
right all right which is not stressful
entire life is stress tell them okay you
die oh that is enormous stress so this
is not because there is something wrong
with anybody's life it's simply because
it's like you have a car it's supposed
to go on four wheels try to drive on one
okay one may look like too much try to
drive one two well within 10 miles your
tires will burst
because too much stress on one point
other things are not being used this is
all that's happening to human beings in
the yoga culture
first eight years
or actually eight and a half years
is considered childhood
so these are not counted though
balawasta is up to 12. it's the eight
and a half years where you're a real
child you know it from your own
experience after you're eight and a half
only your parents thought you were a
child but you were secretly many things
yes
adults think that you are a child but
you know you are not one
because your childhood in many ways ends
at eight and a half
so if you take two side solar Cycles
which is uh
24 years or little less than that
and add eight and a half years to it
it will become
32 and 3 4 or something like this
32 years in seven months or somewhere
there
exact calculations we can make but it's
nearly 33 years
so when these two cycles end
the balavastha
living that when it ends
it is a possibility
this is a time when your life could take
on a different level of propulsion
if you have prepared yourself well
either with education or some skill or
yoga or
inner dimensions of your life if you
have prepared yourself on any of these
things that is the time when it can
Propel or that is the time when it can
start crashing
you know in the western societies they
talk about mid-life crisis
it usually starts around 33 34 years of
age
suddenly people don't know what to do
with themselves
life getting meaningless or those who
are successful they find
traction and suddenly they explode into
different levels of success or
well-being
all this can happen
because
within the system it has completed a
certain cycle either it can take off or
it can crash you can simplicit
if you learn to Simply sit
you will become tremendously intense
right now your energy simply expanded by
doing unnecessary
endless activity
when you have so much
mental diarrhea how can you have energy
suppose you have diarrhea do you see how
weak you feel
so no
right now this mental diarrhea that's
why people have no energy
they want to just eat and sleep all the
time because mental diarrhea it's very
exhausting
foreign
if you have physical diarrhea you know
how exhausting it is
yes
this is also equally exhausting
people are sleeping eight hours ten
hours a day
not because they're working so much or
their body is in such a bad state
just mental diarrhea
if you stop the mental diarrhea there's
enough energy to make this very very
intense
now how do I stop mental area
if you have diarrhea physical diarrhea
what is the first thing to do
huh
what
yes run to the toilet I know that
I'm saying
as a as a corrective measure what is the
first thing you do
foreign
[Music]
but diarrhea means in some way we've
eaten something that the body doesn't
want
it's trying to throw it out
yes
you've taken something inside which the
body doesn't like it wants to throw it
out first thing is
stay away from food for some time
you eat bad food and then try to stop
diarrhea it's not going to work
so similarly bad food for the mind is
just this
you have gotten identified with things
that you are not
the moment you get identified with
things that you are not
mental diarrhea is inevitable
it's bad food for the mind now it will
run endlessly do what you want you do
any damn meditation you say Shiva Rama
it's not going to stop
it's not stopped isn't it
because bad food is being eaten every
day you're getting identified with more
and more things and you want to stop
your mind
you do whatever kind of circus
it is not going to stop
if you disidentify with everything
if you understand what is you and what
is not you
if you keep a little distance from that
mind will become still
if you want you can use it otherwise you
can keep it
now my hand is there if I want I can
move it otherwise I can keep it this is
a useful hand suppose it starts jumping
like this
you clearly know
there is some kind of an ailment isn't
it
yes or no
so if hand is jumping you know it's an
ailment if mind is jumping is it an
ailment or no
oh
the element has come because continuous
wrong diet
you tell your mind
that I am this I am this I am that I am
that
it's having diarrhea
you stop giving it wrong food
if you clearly see what even if you do
not know what is me at least you know
what is not me isn't it
this much you do
tonight before you go to bed
sit on your bed
and sit down and discount everything
that is not you
this house in Europe in which you're
living is this me
no
this loving parent or mother father wife
or husband or child
they're wonderful buddy is this me
no
no these nice clothes I'm wearing is
this me no
now my body I like it but is this me no
now I am having so many thoughts is this
me no
now I'm having wonderful emotions is
this me no
like this everything that's not you
before you sleep keep it down and go to
bed
tomorrow morning you will wake up
considerably more intense than today
this happened in your school maybe later
in your University later in your work
it's happening to people maybe not
everyone but a whole lot of people
their commitment to success is weak
they want to succeed they will take
three steps then something little
interesting happens here they will go
away here they'll go over there they'll
go with it hey I want to live
their commitment to success is weak
uh either situations around them in some
way you know situations can impede you
from doing what you're doing very easily
many times it happens to everyone
but when this happens people weaken
their commitment for their success
maybe physically they'll feel a little
weak
they will weaken their commitment to
success maybe their emotions loss around
a little bit
they will weaken their commitment to
success
this is very important right now
however long it takes this virus
you must come out of this successfully
that means you will stay alive that's an
important part
[Music]
and
commitment to staying alive
should not be slackened no matter what
happened somebody very dear to us passed
away all the more important we must live
[Music]
people around us are all sick all the
more important we are healthy to take
care of the people around us
so our commitment to success should not
weaken because there is social drama
going on or physiological drama or
psychological drama whatever happens
your commitment to success should not
weaken that is what get you across so
many lines in our life so many barriers
in our life
foreign
[Applause]
look like
what does it take
[Music]
you must understand
those who made any significant
achievements in their life
ah they did not
[Music]
you know
I don't want to take any personal
examples of anybody I'm trying to avoid
obvious things that are coming to my
mind
[Music]
well uh
you know I know
family and friends
who always have their breakfast on time
and after breakfast of course they must
have coffee
after coffee of course they must light
up a cigarette and sit there nicely
because they're trying to become
peaceful
[Music]
and then they will go to work
come back home exactly on time for lunch
eat lunch
rest for one or two hours sleep
then evening have one tea and then smoke
and then again go to work
and eight eight o'clock 8 30 they're
back home for dinner and then maybe
other things drink and this and that and
whatever
thank you
well that's their priority
it's fine I'm not complaining it should
not be that way
but those who have been very successful
either in music sport art business
spiritual process doesn't matter what
those people
never know when they hate when they
slept when they got afternoon rest
I have not seen such a thing in my life
yeah
so uh
those who are committed to being
successful with whatever they are doing
one important aspect of their life is
they are not settling down wherever it's
a bit comfortable
because Comfort will happen when they
lower you to in the grave very
comfortable you are you know let one
human being honestly say
when you are with your most loving
parents however doting and wonderful
they were to you
that you never felt this is not where
you want to be
that is a dishonest human being
because
love gets tedious
somebody's fondness gets very tedious
Comfort gets tedious
because the nature of life is it wants
to constantly expand
if there is no room for expansion it
doesn't matter you are kept in a uh
whatever I won't use because everybody
uses the word Golden Palace I think
Golden Palace is totally anesthetic in
my uh
my visual perception I hate Golden
Palace but whatever is the most
wonderful Palace
or as you say Shangri-La whatever
you will it'll get tedious
all the heaven-bound people
they don't know how bored they will be
within three days in that place of
goodness
so I am saying it doesn't matter it's
not because there's something wrong with
your parents
they may be most wonderful people
but
the very nature of a human being is such
only if you are a pet animal
if you have reduced yourself to that
you're just happy
with the means that you're getting and
somebody is fondling you once in a way
and you're happy with that
for that you must be a pet animal you
should not be born as a human being once
you're born as a human being it is
natural wanting to break
barriers so when you're young as a child
or a teenager you think barriers means
they're all physical before you
understand the barriers are not really
physical whether you build your own
house or you live in your parents house
or you live in a slave master's house
the house and walls are not the barrier
it is all within us before you realize
that or how soon you realize that will
lead to either transformation or
frustration don't utter the word freedom
because freedom is a consequence it's
something that you have to earn it
doesn't come as a philosophy in 60s we
thought it's a philosophy
if you live responsibly you will see
Freedom will come when I say responsibly
not in the sense of civic responsibility
if you retain your ability to respond to
life
without any prejudice
without any restriction you will see you
will become free
your ability to respond if it is
unlimited it is freedom the notion of
the difference between pain and
suffering I thought was very useful
it's a pain is physiological it's there
if there's no pain most people would not
even know how to protect themselves
see just because there's no pain in the
see what all you have done to it
isn't it see there's no pain in this so
that's why you took it off if there's no
pain in your nose
maybe you would have taken it off right
because the many advantages you will
take in about 22 extra oxygen if you
just remove this one thing contraption
[Laughter]
wherever there is no pain people are
messing with it like crazy isn't it they
call this hairstyle they call it so many
things yeah
Suppose there was no pain in the entire
body in Los Angeles people would pull
out their stomach bag and
you think they wouldn't do it no that's
probably what
only pain is helping them to preserve
themselves isn't it so pain is good
there's no physiological pain most
people would not know I hear in United
States there's one group they call
themselves something I forget that word
they're actually cutting their fingers
off their hands off on the video
wow they're posting it online
there's a group like that wow can you
imagine this no in spite of so much pain
if there was no pain almost everybody
would have cut themselves off into in
the name of fashion they would have cut
themselves into ribbons wow
so pain is a good thing physically
because that is your
preservation self-preservation mechanism
but suffering is something that you do
in your mind
so pain that happens in your body you
take it in your mind and multiply it a
thousand times or a million times
depending on how capable you are or how
stupid you are and suffer it a million
times over
right now most human beings are like
this what happened 10 years ago they can
still suffer
what may happen day after tomorrow they
already suffer
they are not suffering life they think
they are suffering life they are not
suffering life they are suffering the
two most fantastic faculties that human
beings alone have a vivid sense of
memory and a fantastic sense of
imagination why does one person need a
well by prescription these days eight
hours is it seven seventy eight hours
seven hours sleep
seven hours
and why another person can do with half
of that
see one thing is
as we already went through the very
physical body that you carry is just the
food that you've eaten isn't it
you are looking at Food only as protein
vitamin mineral like this
but we're talking about a food chain
that means
they're all different kinds of lives
what we consume is another form of life
every animal consumes another form of
life this is the way the food cycle is
created
so in what condition that life is will
determine
in what condition your life is in many
ways
so you food appears in front of me if I
just look at it uh people have prepared
it with their elaborate care if I just
look at it I say no
this is Guru this girl this lady has
brought it she's a very good cook she's
very tasty
I just look it in a channel
simply because it's not alive enough for
me it may be tasty but it's not alive
enough for me
if it's not alive enough I will not
consume if you're just conscious of this
one thing
you will see your sleep quota will go
down
another thing is most people are eating
at least 50 50 means hundred percent
more than what they need to eat
yes you you will do one thing as an
experiment just try this whatever you're
eating cut it down by 50 percent
if you're eating let's say uh two
kilograms of food cut it down to one
kilogram and eat variety of foods you
will see you will neither drop weight
nor will you become weak nor will you
become less energetic only thing that
will happen is your sleep quota will go
down
because you are putting so much food to
generate the same same amount of energy
you're eating more by compulsion of
liking the taste or simply by compulsion
of filling yourself up now the body has
to press process so much food to create
so much energy this extra processing is
taking a toll on the system
the amount of impurities that are there
in the food will also determine how how
much inertia you generate in the body
let's understand it this way in terms of
physical terms what sleep means is
inertia right now your Dynamic this is
life inertia said sin
when inertia goes beyond a certain point
that's death
but sleep is a certain kind of death but
it is offering you rest
so restfulness is very important
what is being restful means is
if you sit here if you're a total ease
you will see the body is naturally
restful if you have you noticed on a
particular day you are very happy on
that day you don't need much sleep or
food have you noticed this
that's all you have to do
if you remain very joyful every moment
of your life the food will come down
sleep will come down naturally I don't
know I never looked at Life as a series
of mistakes learning from that I don't
look at life like that
well
have you done made some dumb decisions
here and there of course but
uh
I wouldn't see them as mistakes I just
see them as part of growing up and
becoming more mature because
Enlightenment is one thing you see
things clearly but still operating in
the world you need wisdom wisdom you
have to earn it with experience there is
simply no other way for that today it
has become fashionable with all these
management gurus and all saying You must
learn from your mistakes you must learn
mistakes that means you must keep on
doing mistakes I don't believe that you
must learn from your mistakes I would
rather live a life where I don't do any
mistakes
because life is so brief you do a bunch
of mistakes and then you will learn and
where will you use it in the grave too
late so let's learn from other people's
mistakes yeah and yes of course
of course human means that we can learn
from other people's experience from
history we can learn we don't have to do
all those things once again and
especially you are from the aviation
state if you are trying Aviation or if
you're trying skydiving or something if
you don't do things right the first time
well that will be the last time
unfortunately
in many ways not just in the way that I
said now in many different ways I would
say
70 percent of illnesses on the planet
all kinds
are self-created even if you get an
infection there is a way if you keep
yourself in a certain way physically and
mentally
the virus in the bacteria will not work
the same way as it works upon somebody
else
if you said to yourself like this
no matter what's happening
anyway I have to go and do this this and
this there's no break from that
the last 29 years
I have not been able to cancel one
program because I'm running temperature
I got a cold I got this I got that
it doesn't matter what's happening what
you have to do you anyway have to do you
can't turn back on that
either out of your commitment or you
have a boss like that
one or one way or the other if it
happens
then you will see
you will not at all fall sick so often
because if you have temperature
you still have to go if it's summer you
still go right
now a lot of people don't go it's a
little hot outside they don't go and
work a little cold outside they don't go
and work a little raining they won't go
on work a snowflake they will not go on
work
this is just weather
so for every change in weather
if you have the comfort of covering
yourself in a blanket and lying down
once you create that your body will
learn to fall sick as often as possible
if you just keep it this way it doesn't
matter
what it is anyway I have to go and do
what I have to do you will see your body
will just bounce back
as quickly as possible even if it gets
the worst kind of infections
so you just have to set the necessary
conditions for health necessary in
incentives for help both for yourself
and your children if you have them
do not set incentives for sickness if
you're paying too much attention to
everything around you not enough
attention to this one but the quality of
your life is essentially determined by
how you carry this one
yes or no
this moment
what kind of clothes you're wearing
what kind of card you parked outside
what kind of home you live in does not
determine the quality of your life this
moment how joyful are you feeling within
yourself determines the quality of your
life isn't it so
nothing has been done about it you think
it will happen in consequence
and you're setting impossible goals for
your happiness if I have to be happy my
wife should be like this my husband
should be like that my children should
be like this the world should become
some other way
well these are impossible conditions
you're setting for your happiness and
peacefulness
now that you have compromised yourself
to peace
why I'm saying compromise yourself to
pieces
because a lot of people have given up
aspirations for being ecstatic or
Blissful if I'm just peaceful it's
enough even the so-called spiritual
leaders are going about and saying peace
is the highest goal in your life
peace is not the highest goal in your
life if you want to enjoy your lunch
today you must be peaceful
yes or no
if you're not even peaceful there is
nothing in your life that you can do in
a worthwhile way
to be peaceful essentially means this
that you're not messing your mind
to be peaceful means
that your system is at ease you know how
to conduct your mind you know how to
conduct your emotions your body and your
energies you are peaceful
it is not a rocket technology
it is the most basic thing you have a
dog at home you give him his food he
sits peacefully
maybe not ecstatic but peacefully many
times they are ecstatic also
yes
if your dog is able to sit please oh he
doesn't have to run my industry
that's not the point he's got his own
stuff going
[Music]
see it has nothing to do with the
external activity that you're doing it's
got something to do with the internal
systems as to how they're functioning
essentially it means either neither your
body nor your mind or your Chemistry or
your emotions nor your energy or taking
instructions from you they're doing
their own thing
once your machine is not in your control
being peaceful is impossible I'll tell
you you get into your car
and now you go there and you want to
turn this way you do this to the
steering it goes this way
can you peacefully drive this car
can you no anxiety is natural isn't it
this is what has happened to your
vehicle it's out of control
you've never done anything to find out
where the steering wheel is first of all
this is not that simple as a car this is
a super super computer now the problem
is most people have not even bothered to
find the keyboard
they think if they do this somehow it
will work
if you make when you're given such a
highly sophisticated machine if you do
not conduct it properly it will cause
many problems to you
by accident it's working I want you to
know this this is made this way if you
hold your hands like this it'll breathe
one way if you just turn it around the
very way you breathe the breathing
pattern itself changes in your lungs you
can try it if you want when you have the
time this way this way I'm saying
everything that you do
fundamental changes are happening in
this machine because it's such a
sophisticated machine
it's more than a touch screen if you
just wish it it will happen
when you have such a sensitive and
sophisticated machine and you are
operating like a blacksmith
then being peaceful seems to be
difficult
peace is not the highest goal in your
life it is the most fundamental
requirement don't ever set peace as the
highest goal if you do that you will
only rest in peace
you must see to be peaceful is the first
thing in your life isn't it if you want
to do anything sensibly in your life
if you want to do conduct any situation
in your life sensibly to be peaceful and
happy is fundamental
voice isn't it
so why is it so much unpleasantness is
happening in Human Experience
because we never took charge of the
inner dimension
We Believe by fixing the outside
everything is going to be okay
in the last 150 years with the Advent of
Science and modern technology
we have fixed too many things on the
outside
if you fix any more there won't be a
planet left
yes
definitely this has brought much
convenience and comfort to our lives in
every way we are the most comfortable
generation ever
you agree with me
I know you have series of complaints
about how things are not okay but we are
the most comfortable generation ever
before on this planet isn't it so
but we cannot say we are the most joyful
generation on the planet we are the most
loving generation on the planet we are
the most blissed out generation in the
planet definitely not
we are complaining complaining like
crazy about everything like never before
this is because we fixed the outside
comfort and conveniences happen
well-being has not happened
if
your interiority was handled by you
consciously you would definitely keep
this in a blissful state
so he's Bliss the goal of life no
Bliss is a necessary condition for life
to flower to its full potential
otherwise it will remain constrained
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from gorugo Paul does
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
see you there do you know something in
the game of life you're playing a
cricket match against an entity called
the mind no one on planet Earth can stop
you from accomplishing and achieving
what you want